what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
episode of our podcast here at any
mapper called
rant cafe this is episode 33 already we
do this every week Thursday at 5 or 5
fish Eastern Standard Time sometimes we
run a bit late but you know how it goes
welcome everyone in the chat I see you
guys in there and welcome to my guest
this week we have an American all-day
anime soul maka and hopefully we might
get cyanide blizzard joining us later as
well he's running a bit late what's up
everybody what's up man
pleasure to be here like already you
already [ __ ] got one dislike oh sorry
about that
somebody just somebody just pressed
dislike it removed it immediately yeah I
was you it was no I'm just playing recon
basically guys we're gonna be today
talking about the greatest wet villains
in anime in our opinion obviously having
a little discussion amongst ourselves
and with you guys Chad I thought it
would be a cool thing to talk about
because we just recently last week
released a video on explaining all the
villains in my near academia and while
making that video I thought it was quite
fun to consider all these different
villains and villains in anime in
general and what makes them so
interesting even though by conventional
standards they're not good people they
don't do good things necessarily but yet
they still we still find it interesting
so I thought that would be a good topic
for discussion yeah I think villains are
some sometimes the most important
characters and cff he's shown in series
like for example Dragon Ball Z I think
it's good and like I like it cuz of
nostalgia but the villains are always
very basic and I feel like there's evil
for the sake of being evil and then what
makes this show good is if you could
have a really like well-thought-out and
really interesting villain it's cause
like the protagonist is mainly reacting
to what the villain does so the villain
is that sometimes I'm open like more
important than the protagonist connect
an arquebus shown into for example
that's why I like like I think one piece
you talk about won't be first I can hear
guys like I think they do the glans very
well and that's what take this shown in
from being good to being great if the
the Ark's can be like driven by like the
villain if they have backstories or well
fleshed out it have a reason for why
they are evil or why they are doing what
they're doing it makes you like attach
you maybe want the hero to win more even
more or maybe have a little sympathy for
the villain but anyway go ahead soul
maka ya know yeah I was gonna say that
sounding reason in one piece though but
yeah yeah yeah I totally agree but it's
just sometimes sometimes like in the
series on the whole I don't like it when
too much focus is on the villain and
then you're like the user is an excuse
to then just make your main character
just really plan because they're like oh
so long we've got a great villain you
know it doesn't really matter because
all he has to do is react to it yeah I
mean I prefer to go to standalone like
you know by their own merit but yeah
with with villains definitely they have
to be I think relatable that's the main
thing I think they have to be like there
has to be some kind of logic there using
that you can understand and relate to it
and be like yeah yeah I get that yeah to
be light you know I agree with you 100%
on that I never liked villains that are
like just psycho for the sake of being
psycho you know evil for the sake of
being evil I always wanted to have an
actual logic where you can actually
sympathize with them in some way you
might think they're going about it the
wrong way but you're like yeah I can
understand where this person is coming
from what they're trying to achieve
right so I think that's an hugely
important thing in terms of a good
making a good villain nock stock when
the Chad says the villain breakdown
master is here and yes Knox that's why I
would love to have have you here on the
podcast talking about it because Knox
has made several breakdowns of what
makes a good villain on this channel but
he said he was too busy for us guys he
said he was too busy for us I wish he
was here
Sufjan also asked do we think that
Reiner and Berthold would be building a
good villains and that's one thing that
about attack on Titan that's very
interesting it's like you don't know who
is the villain right who is the villain
here because our Titans villains they're
mindless most of them right they're
mindless um can you really call them
villains they're just like you know a
wild rabbit animal are
evil orders they're just doing what they
have you know the yeah yeah with you
know if you read the manga of attack on
Titan as soul I know you do you know
that these guys Ryan are brutal and
stuff even though they seem like
villains they have their own reasoning
they have their own logic their own
motivations their own upbringing that
they were they were they were
essentially you know brainwash to
believe certain things right so so it's
a lot it's very complex and attack on
Titan in terms of who is the villain and
then we know that inside them the walls
there's villains as well right so that's
I think that's interesting very
interesting in terms of attack on Titan
yeah I don't know but for characters for
me for characters like where Reiner and
Berto
I don't think they make good villains in
a sense of a villain because basically
just following orders it's not their own
will yeah I mean they don't want to have
to do this they're forced to do this
yeah they're not really going off of
like their own ideals yeah I mean
they're just soldiers when they were
there and they were living with them
they started relating to the people that
were there they started liking being
around people that were there and then
after when I started having like the
breakdown moment of you know realizing
no you're a soldier you have to destroy
these people you know I mean not not be
one of them not not feel part of them
you have to destroy them you know I from
when you seen that it's like yeah this
guy ain't getting really a villain he's
just pushed into a corner because of the
powers that be and he has to now do this
role but if he offers like if he had a
freedom of choice he probably wouldn't
do it
yo can I just say one thing soul madness
is in the [ __ ] Chad man I love that
guy's channel what's up bro and his
choice of Griffith with his fantastic
palace I'll be near me my first choice
if someone asked me like one of my
favorite villains just letting how he
was driven to becoming a villain and
like getting back at guts was fantastic
at the end of like I guess the first
dark or the first 35 episodes and I
kinda got started from there the series
you're talking about breakfast Christmas
Griffith from
zurk actually is a very good filum
prefer you know we all know him for
[ __ ] raping Kostka it's quite obvious
that's a huge [ __ ] villain for doing
that yeah it was just to get back at God
step with it yeah left him and that's
why everything was like led to him
getting tortured and getting like did he
did what he did and I think how he
became a villain in the series and he
started off as it's like pure like white
knight type of guy was really cool I
think he's not he's a great villain I
really enjoyed mazurka season 2 was
actually much more better than the first
I think that's a misconception of
Griffith I think Griffith was evil but
it's just because it's rich trading
because because he needed like the
debond in it the band of the hawk he
would look after them
yeah once he got to like the states of
ok he don't need them now
sacrifice them that was it boom because
it was always all about him achieving
his goal yeah I mean like you can't say
oh yeah he was a white knight good guy
and then he's there or doing guts to go
kill kids and [ __ ] yeah I mean though I
mean you know how the he was ever good
but he was like perceived to being like
the perfect individual and then they was
driven to this point of like at the end
raping Koska killing all the people that
was close to me really show that they
were literally just pawns and his like
in his eyes type of thing and I guess
probably getting the - spoiler territory
here but yeah on that note tolson a says
best villain is Anna Mack yes there are
pawns in my game baby you are all pawns
in my game um another thing snorts he's
like what do you think about betting
goose from re0 that guy was so awful
jeez I [ __ ] hate that man he's he's a
good young dinner he's a crazy a yandere
right module read the [ __ ] and like he
has this crazy idea G obsession with the
winch so he just goes around killing in
her name and all this stuff like yeah
he's a crazy character like he's
completely insane right but he also
like this motivation of like religious
zealotry which makes some kind of
interesting but yeah definitely you want
them to get murdered as soon as possible
like not of no one's gonna be a fan of
that guy but still pretty interesting
about metal geese is like huge villain
for me back and reasoner for actually
killing rum because the first time when
he you guys remember that episode when
he twisted Bream all the way just in
front of ya it was just [ __ ] terrible
and not just that but he can also take
over people's body just this is the way
he did to Subaru so he ended up killing
himself because he didn't want to yeah
yeah well what Sony it's only certain
people's bodies in it people's body was
the fingers yeah yeah yeah the people
who have come into contact with the
Bible thing or everyone yeah okay I'm
also gonna have to open this up SAO
villains number ones like I uh do you
remember that elf guy back in elf I'm on
mine that's right - you know Ray
possible yeah I wouldn't say they're
just okay you know the Heathcliff thing
like it's like he's interesting but it's
like what is his motivation but I did
I thought death gun was a pretty
interest oh yeah death gun was also good
that's alright like what that's what
goes for me hey I'm going home it could
being great like the motivation why are
they doing what they're doing but even
if they're just a psychopath path like
let us understand why he is or like show
that that's the reason or show that like
why they're doing what they're doing
type of thing and I need to talk about
what nook stop who said can you can you
do with a favor and please hype doe fee
for me and the Sakamoto Flamingo from
one piece and like so Mac I said Oda has
been recently trying to like he's been
really developing his antagonists and
like I think he really should like the
arc was like a three year arc
essentially we've been watching the same
dressrosa art for three years and
doleful mingle with a fantastic villain
like he was born
and it was picked out of like I remember
the places we're like nobles and like he
was kind of like tortured mistreated his
entire life so we kind of understood why
he was so crazy even though he was kind
of like not a good person to begin with
and you understand why he became such a
terrible person and why I did what he
did
we also sympathize with him a little bit
because of how like mistreated he was so
like you're able to understand what he's
doing but at the same time because how
like care of the terrible stuff he's
doing now he wanted me to pick his ass
all the more yeah I don't know I think
those are the that's right
because the ones where it's like you
want them to be defeated because they're
doing evil things but you can also
understand where they're coming from and
it's not like this guy is a complete
monster it's like you know maybe if my
life was that messed up or something
would happen to be maybe I would sing
this way too it's not a good thing but
you know it makes you think about the
nature of humanity and like a lot of
villains become villains out of revenge
and interesting things like that table
[ __ ] a case I know Blizzard has been
low-key in here what's up man greetings
good sir everyone else and I got a say
on a Mac building upon that you are
absolutely right see for me I've only
watched the first season of sword art
online but to be honest I detest the
villains in the show because there they
are bad guys but they're not developed
bad guys in order for a villain to be
developed you need those shades of gray
you need to understand what corrupted
them why it did and how it affects them
his sympathy also works real well I find
that characters like Griffith or even
let's flash over to try gun for
character like Legolas
you know his whole objective is to make
Vash the Stampede suffer to the point of
not necessarily ruining his life but to
moreso break him as a person and we get
where he comes from and why he's like
that as the story unfolds and it becomes
you feel for the main character you feel
for the secondary character and thus the
characters become more fleshed out and
developed overall they feel more
multi-dimensional instead of one
dimension which unfortunately is a
problem animatic I'm sure you know this
is a writer that a lot of villains run
into is they lack that fleshing out that
development so
sure you know about that as well from
your own experience yeah and I think
it's funny that every time someone says
something bad about sort of online the
read guy is just like [ __ ] you because
you guys just cross over the series when
it's really good I mean when it's not
right
cyanide like you said about Kayaba not
being about the villains not being
developed by mean Kayaba did clearly
explained his reasoning for you know
doing this it's because he meant si oh
I'm cried is meant to be like this the
game is supposed to be like this from
the very very beginning is that when
people die in the video game they die in
real life he made this game for a reason
for it to be like this that's that's the
whole story behind why did he do that
though but why though like what reason
to the abbé to commit mass genocide well
it's his game and he decided to do it
like this that's his reasoning so just
because I genocide it's just mass oh
yeah yeah you know but yes so people
have a reason for why they like would
commit mass murder type of thing yeah it
says stupid as him just wanted to play
in a video game where the stakes are
high
well if you understand why he's doing it
well that wasn't the reason I made it up
on the spot but like you want to
understand why something as crazy as
dying in a game was created yeah I would
understand if it was something like um
makishima show go from Psychopaths where
he believes society is corrupt that it's
going to be destroyed and like it's
destroying itself so he wants to shock
it awake with doing horrible things
so while even you would never agree with
what he's doing you're thinking well he
kind of has a point in thermal what's
what society is turning into you know
we're becoming we're coming slaves with
the whole psycho passes and people of
being arrested for pre crimes
essentially and I think if an SI Oh with
that was played up more where this guy's
like I created this game to show you
that modern technology is destroying our
humanity and we can destroy our lives
and literally kill us and look here's
how a hacker with you know what's enough
tech expertise can just kill a bunch of
people something needs to change
no they you know he doesn't play that up
his motivation
complete like what the [ __ ] and that
also not only that but people keep
playing these games keep playing these
same games where they can die in it keep
playing new ones
the thing is they do something in dot
hack was a predecessor and sorta online
when initially came out earned a lot of
comparisons because the thing is is that
dot hack was structured the same way
except something was happening in the
game to where people were going into
comas and it became this big issue which
when was it was resolved the prospect
was that hey look this isn't gonna
happen again
we saw the issue but then something else
developed whereas in this case as you
said the entire concept this was built
so that would happen but and now we're
not saying that sort online is bad and
people are welcome to like what they
want to like there's plenty of things I
can see in there as the white people
like it but as I need to know we need to
know like what reason do you have to
create it was it simply to show people
was it to teach people the value of life
because of the fact that technology
takes up so much of our lives you know
we just so much does everything as a
convenience that we don't realize what
it actually could do to us you know that
there are dangers to technology as well
you know it's what what's the overall
lesson that we the audience or the
characters are learning from the villain
doing this what's the overall never been
amazing yeah and like you know I don't
like the whole Power Rangers if you guys
remember the Power Rangers Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers villains where
it's like they're just evil for the sake
of being evil like we're evil because we
want to destroy the good people right so
that that to me is not that interesting
and snore Li in the chat he really knows
how to get noticed by me
asks about the anti spirals from Gurren
Lagann and I mean that means like
explaining what it is as if he needs to
explain it to me Jesus
anyways Spyro King the anti spirals the
anti spirals which is basically they
used to be living beings in the universe
like us who decided that spiraled power
because spiral power in their world you
know human spirit potential is so
destructive because it fuels in a war
and battle and destruction
that they decided to essentially turn
themselves into a collective
consciousness that has no emotions and
that is only strictly hundred-person
rational and they decided to on that
basis destroy the spirals people who do
act a based on emotion and spirit rather
than a pure rationality they decided to
keep them down and destroy them if they
ever get powerful enough because they
genuinely feel that the whole universe
will be destroyed by this power if they
let it run free so it's a very
interesting thing you know the
philosophy deals with this a lot you
whole concept of emotions versus
rationality can you have one without the
other
you know the whole enlightenment
movement was about you know we're moving
away from religious belief before going
to science to being rational and then
there was a counter movement with him
via night men like my favorite
philosopher jean-jacques Rousseau who
was all about no no we are driven by you
know emotions like love and stuff like
that we feel we feel before we think so
we can't you know pretend that that is
not a huge part of who we are so I think
that's a fascinating debate and that's
why again Gurren Lagann is my favorite
anime of all time because of such
important issues that it raises good job
snore Lee for bringing that up what do
you guys think we're currently having a
war or not sort out all night I think
show toka is the worst villain than any
villain presented in soda online who
well I don't think of the bad take
villain we all hate him because he kind
of did his job as a villain he was cool
he got cornered and he was like his
motivation with fitty he just wanted to
continue to like make money and work for
they like the government or whatever so
that he was cornered and used his wife
and then he was quartered and used his
daughters everything if we're talking of
the same character here so it's like at
least we understand why he did it and
it's a terrible thing and we all hate it
I mean he makes the better villain than
any villain and si oh oh oh yeah he's
more of a bad guy in it like the first
guy in Sao the creator of the game like
he's not that evil I mean you could say
okay the game
made was bad but he wasn't like
deliberately killing people there was
loads the safe zones if people just hung
out in the safe zones no one would die
yeah
he then also once the game got done gave
all whites of the game to Kabuto yeah I
mean he gave like the master control to
Kirito then the other guy comes in and I
mean or all he's after is Asuma that's
it yeah that's that's always after money
I mean if you don't care about us you
know then this villain has no power at
all over anything you think yeah I mean
and then obviously the other guy he is a
natural like a killer but I don't know I
didn't throw any motivation from him
yeah we would show tucker he like he
loses his mind because he is sold his
identity is so connected with his job of
being an inventor right a scientist yes
a man and that's his job and he's afraid
he's gonna lose his job and there's so
much pressure and then he loses it and
starts experimenting on his own daughter
right which is completely unforgivable
but like you see his degeneration and
then it speaks to and I'm sure in Japan
it speaks to the kind of social
pressures you have to perform for your
job is so much a part of you you know
many people who lose their job even here
in the West but also in Japan are known
to like commit suicide because they feel
like they have nothing left if they lose
their job because it's so tied to their
identity and who they are which
obviously is wrong completely because
job that your job or anything else
doesn't make who you are your your life
is worthwhile on its own without any
other you know things going on but it's
just yeah I think that it actually makes
you think it makes you not relate but be
like yeah I see where like how he you
know God this warped worldview there is
some kind of logical thing like you
couldn't imagine a real person going
crazy like that but if it's just someone
being evil for the sake of evil stuff
like that then it doesn't it's not as
interesting right bring up quickly one
thing I wanna bring up quickly sorry uh
Briggs is in cold Geass if you guys
remember Charles I thought you
a really interesting villain because
first he's saying one thing we don't as
the guy who's promoting the fact that
all men are not created equal and how
you know we that that's the way it has
to be the strong must ruled to me the
weak must obey and that later we
realized that his actual goal is to
destroy all inequality create perfect
equality through a sort of human
instrumentality project right so I
thought that was that was a really nice
twist in Co vs I think you guys did you
have you as any one here watch Arjun I
have I watched a fantastic villain for
an example is subtle from Arjun like he
is such an interesting villain not just
that but he is such a badass
I love a lesser villain because the
thing is he just wants to have fun
basically as a villain he he wants to
have fun babe because he thinks what he
dies of course an Arjun can resurrect
from the dead but his goal from the very
game from the very beginning was to have
fun because everything to him was just
the game so if he dies he could just get
back up everything doing was just a game
I'm sure I probably could you like he's
a nanjing people were trying to track
him down and torture him it's an entire
life so like he kind of probably like a
sense of reality I don't know I only
watch like I don't think I even well I
lost like all the odds just wanted to
team up with Sato because he thought
because everyone thought that Sato was
gonna bring peace back to the origins
that he's gonna side with the audience
but no he just could he just brought a
whole team of margins so everyone so we
could just have fun with them and just
everything is a game that's why I love
him he's such a badass yeah yeah I think
Sato is again it's interesting because
the Audion are so discriminated against
that it's like you can understand where
he's coming from but I still I just
dislike that show person yeah the
animation is terrible to me and also I
feel like he's just like too too much of
a psycho for the sake of being psycho
like you could you could be
Machiavellian and do it in a better way
than he's doing it like you don't have
to do what he is doing to actually
get what he wants to do and that kind of
puts me off right when someone becomes a
villain you can see that motivation but
then they go too far almost just to like
alienate people more and make more
people hate them it's like you're not
helping yourself if you're doing that if
your goal is to actually fight back and
become you know accepted in society Ram
and enjoy Rome and the Chad says he
likes what Team Rocket like Team Rocket
Pokemon yeah they're just such bad
villains in terms of like they're so
easily defeated they're so lame I don't
know yeah I mean Jesse might not feel
like the comedy comes from from the dis
yeah and you never ask very cliche stare
difficult bad villain what was their
goal anyway other than stealing like
what are you doing it full like just
watch them just catch them they're
everywhere you imagine being a member of
Team Rocket's like so what's our mission
objective we're gonna catch pokemon why
bring it back to their boss because
they're the boss orders they're bought
their boss new ways to steal pokémon
this is my elephant army for world
domination guys come on
this stupid thing about Pokemon it's so
juvenile because in the world of Pokemon
it could be interesting because you
could have wars fought with Pokemon
right
you could have armies of Pokemon or
Pokemon helping armies fight wars like
different people trying to take the
world using poke over the world using
Pokemon legendary Pokemon being used for
that like to me that's interesting if
there was like a more mature version of
Pokemon where that's kind of stuff was
actually okay to show but unfortunately
because Pokemon is such a children's
show they never go there they're only go
to the cliche all want to steal Pikachu
oh I failed at stealing right no it was
only an order take on the world of
Pokemon
it just happens over and over again yeah
it's hard to be analytical on shows like
that flea it's ridiculous like Ashton
getting attacked when there's like the
same Pokemon in wild all over the place
like yeah I mean why take so much
he gets so good by the end of every
season and he sucks the first episode of
the new season ticket who loses like a
church would just got like a new owner
like the day before no but the thing is
when has Team Rocket ever succeeded
never they have never ever succeed no
they don't give up they lose over the
fire and they never give up yeah they do
not give up this is a good thing you
know one way to realize this
Team Rocket are actually great heroes
because they always lose but they never
give up they keep pushing forward yeah
that one's just about the Team Rocket
side people just um just Jessie and
James as I wanted theirs if you like a
spin-offs like what happens inside the
tink Team Rocket headquarters like what
is their boss thinking like why does he
not fire them after failing 1800 times
like what is he like that would be
hilarious to see kind of forgot about
him forgot about them do you know the
Team Rocket model yeah the motor what
they say when they made their appearance
you should know that that's not their mo
does their entrance yeah I know that's
not entrance that's what they do when
they come in trouble make it double dip
to protect the world from devastation to
unite all people within our nation
yeah by stealing for nothing sure they
love yam no like Team Rocket has no like
grounding like what's their ideology
like it's like it's just a mess
but they're good example are just a tool
to simplistic grill and just plot
devices but ship wreck says what about
anime uproar he is a good villain yes
anime uproar is a good I don't know if
we're as good as that enemy snob though
that enemy snob is probably the best
villain expand DX file on Hannah - yeah
but DX fan like he talks about one anime
and he moves on that an arrest op when
he wants to pick on a youtuber he will
make 800 videos on one Coover like he is
he doesn't give up a guy and then
recently to ya know I don't know if you
guys have been watching it but I do like
out there from we clears oh yeah yeah
she's interesting
you know and I even seen not only her
motivations and stuff and a back story
but also seen like how she how she's
wise enough to work out how to empower
herself
I hate though the fact that she actually
killed off magical Slayer Monica I
didn't really like that just because she
spoke about sex you know do not speak of
our end she just decided to [ __ ] kill
her all that is a villain I mean attack
you know it's someone had to die in that
attack but the reason why is she killed
him because she didn't want to she would
didn't want her to talk about setsuna is
because if sets and his death I'm pretty
did you watch about setsuna chose a side
in it she chose to stand against out
here didn't she yes she did so she had
to she started to understand the truth
that's why people yeah yeah I joke she
said she said cuz out here was like oh
well you've only been written like to be
the hero so why why are you doing this
hypocrisy why are you choosing up huff
and she's like no yeah I may have been
written to be that way but now I'm here
I've changed but with why I'm scenes
going on I choose to be that person you
know me then she goes on to talk about
tell sinner then you know then the fight
starts and ends and that's it yeah
that's she's an interesting villain
because I get it raises questions about
modern society of both technology about
social pressure you know what what kind
of world are we living in like when
those questions are being raised I think
it's uh that's what makes a good anime
and a good villain
however guys I will tell you I read that
and the manga for recreator zai know
everything that's gonna happen so
I won't spoil it for you but it's crazy
what about Magan a psychotic uniform
groceries a [ __ ] Allison woman no I
don't like the whole thing of she's
saying but why yeah exactly
why does yoen I mean yeah it's funny
interesting you know um you know the way
that she could take something from you
or use young words against you kind of
thing
she can flip though was it the laws of
something she likes to mind Hawaii or
light light was like and slide then
becomes the truth or something later
yeah man yeah it's wit yes what but
Lawrence and the chat says Pegasus from
yugioh is not even willing because he's
gay motivation why he does what he does
men like him Sokka I can't be scared of
him he's gay sorry it doesn't work nan I
seen an enchantment floor
what up floor someone mentioned light a
few people mentioned Light Yagami in the
chat
you'd be I'm antihero rather than a
villain because he is actually the main
guy of the show and he is like you here
thinking he's gonna be our hero our
protagonist but meanwhile he's doing all
this crazy stuff so he's more of a and
here antihero but again he does have
motivations that make sense you know he
wants to rid society is corrupt there's
so much wrong he no one else is doing
anything he wants to do something about
it he wants to rid the world of
injustice but then again the question is
does he go way too far and that kind of
stuff so that is again a good example or
good no but the problem the problem with
light though is he has no justification
for that like if he if he was someone
like that was bullied in high school and
stuff and you know he had like a road
deep down hatred against injustice and
you know then you
that that serves as like a foundation to
his beliefs and then he starts doing it
then yeah you know that's the small
relatable but this guy was like top of
the class everyone like same you know
not really hated and you know he just
then decides this yeah I mean I think
because it was like a perfect person ego
thing like the ego trip with it is all
and he's like ya know like it's a mask
with that's just it you know he gives
off this impression but that's not who
he actually is and that's sort of you
know peeling behind the veil type thing
which I mean that's just it he does I
think he teeters on the line between
being a villain and being an antihero as
well cuz as you said so you made a very
good point there but like Adam acted as
well I made a really good point regards
that those are both things that really
need to be considered when you look at
the character and you look at his
actions and why he's doing those actions
yeah and it's like cuz his motivation is
not bad like his initial motivation is
to bring justice to the world to punish
people who do bad things because you
know the law is not punishing and
they're getting there slipping through
the cracks but then it's the way he goes
about it that then is up for debate well
I definitely understand soul lights
motivation because he's a very
intelligent guy who is looking at the
world he sees all these injustice is
happening happening he sees all this
hypocrisy and corruption and he sees no
one doing anything about it and he's
like you know what I'm sick of this I I
can see what's wrong
I can I know a way to fix it I have the
power so I'm gonna do it so I think that
like I could personally relate to him
maybe cuz I'm so smart but I feel like I
can relate to him but then I would not
go about it the way he did like he was
gonna want to become a detective or a
cop anyway like because he wanted to
like solve these crimes and like like
kind of like prevent injustice and then
a death that falls near his hand and
like you so it's like okay now I could
do that but even more on a grand scale
but then along the way he starts to
become like wanna become a god and like
he starts losing his path and like doing
things that aren't just type of thing
yeah yeah yeah I think that's the
problem he ends up like being a serial
killer himself killing
all these innocent people to fight for
the rights of the normal people to keep
them safe you know please half bi in
different things like that yeah I mean
so then it you know it becomes very
questionable like you know because he
seems more self-serving than
self-sacrificing yeah I mean like
nothing for himself if you were like
killing millions of people were like
thousands of people billion think you
might go a little mad or a little bit
power hunk like like power crazy but I
feel like it kind of makes sense it's
character yeah let me we'll actually
don't do it's like such power would
definitely corrupt someone right yeah he
had a dress code on the beginning but
slowly you lost himself along the way
well do they save the road to hell is
paved with good intentions so and at
that sort of kind of an interesting
perspective of that is you know how much
you sympathize with the character and
understanding you sort of watched that
descent and then that's you know when
when L is introduced so I mean or you
know then that's when we kind of work
off that we see the dynamic between them
and how they interact of each other
because the way L is portrayed is he's
technically lights villain but light is
more seen as a bad guy because action so
you know you sort of start understanding
almost the duality which is for me what
made the arc really interesting between
the two yeah and the other interesting
thing about L 2 is he does a lot of
unethical and you know arguably immoral
things to get Kira because he thinks
that the ends justify the means
so he's not like your by-the-book cop
either and that's what makes it
interesting I think the dynamic between
the two of them someone mentioned the
child a few people I see lumpiang
mentioned mentioned he stuck out from
hunter hunter yeah I think he's I don't
know he's the best one but he's
definitely cool he's kind of like I
could kill you now but it's too easy
yeah that's kind of like all the same
kind of state trying to say before like
obviously they could be really good
writing you could have a very
well-thought-out villain and his
motivation by the end of the day you can
still have a very cool and badass
villain without having that kind of
having some like mystery behind their
character so like it goes both ways
like we don't nothing what he's a kind
of a story very little from what I
remember and I think he's a badass
really cool villain
- like the protagonist yeah that's the
thing there you know you could have a
cool villain but if you look the really
great ones I would definitely say we
know their background we know their
motivation we can't relate to them we
don't necessarily agree with everything
they're doing but we're like you know
you're not in this in similar
circumstances maybe I would be tempted
to be the same way it right like you can
really relate and I think that's what
makes a great villain I agree what uh
what about monokuma and Junko from
danganronpa if you guys have watch the
series know I watched under you don't
know monokuma the [ __ ] matter I
remember I could name a single character
I know what I look like but that don't
mean I know yes he made it he made the
entire know like person behind the
shadow of him type of thing with yak you
like a real thing I genuinely don't
remember sad way guys glider Cordero in
the chat is asking what we think of the
villains from seven deadly sins so
Briggs I think you can weigh in on that
one I'm gonna have to amuse my mic for
just a sec and check something out but
I'll be back so caring the conversation
I'll let me think about this for a
second
I think the world of the 70s is very
cool like you yeah you have Giants you
got demons you've got goddesses humans
and just like that you're like you're
already gonna create some amount of
friction and I feel the great holy war
before so there'll always be like so I
guess like there is a little bit of
motivation behind it's like a there's a
past and a history after why like the
demons are doing what they're doing the
trying to get revenge
I think the ten commandments are
extremely cool but the first season is a
little bit laughing in cool villains
like I found it very weird how like if
so GILF under whatever he was acting
like a villain in the beginning but
really he was kind of like he had no
other choice I really have does anyone
here else watch the 70 sins
I think the villas are an amazing until
the manga after the first season in my
yeah okay no I am I can't stop my kid I
tried I tried and got about two chapters
into it and then yeah a little drop of
it because it's the characters that
makes me like get into the series like
the main like the seven main characters
or the eight main characters type of
thing are very lovable characters and
like every scene just full of fun the
fights are really cool and stuff like
that I don't think it's an amazing
Sirians like I just like I had a hard
time talking about the villains or not
thoroughly like thought-out like I don't
have like motivations and stuff but one
thing I really do like is the world and
like they go to a lot of detail on like
I've made like 15 videos talking about
the seven deadly sins like every little
thing is actually like very detailed I
don't think the anime does it like I'm
meeting Jonathan it's got to continue
yeah one of the villains I liked in
first
I think what's his name is it aleni who
clue was like old above or whatever the
one that was like kind of controlling
him forcing him like to kill people and
stuff illumi yeah does that guy like
that guy I found more interesting at
first like in the Hunter x Hunter series
compared to Hisoka you know it's okay
he's just young he's wait just like a
clown okay I'll give you probably one of
the greatest villains that ever lived
and here's a hint I want you to take a
guess is she's a lolly and she was a
mercenary outfit and she has blonde hair
Sankyo ever it's a it's Tanya from your
door think easy is [ __ ] amazing as a
villain holy [ __ ] the destruction that
she creates
sine I did a first impression for that
show I don't know I ain't watching
silent person on the show yes did you
like it
it was terrible yeah I was told what
could I do that
that art was so hideous then I checked
out the manga and it looks amazing
so I'm sticking no no I'm that the
concept is actually really clever the
ideas behind it are good as a first
episode I thought it was rather lacking
but no I think that it's there there
definitely elements there too to make
for a great villain but in the first
episode a lot of things just came across
is almost comically villainous like you
know it's Team Rocket blasting up again
type level but no I mean if I know me do
I want to say that I thought the show
was bad I only watched one episode I
have no right to judge so there are
people have another atom a kiss but
there are people Young Buck
there are people threatening to do
horrible things if we don't address
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure so anyone wanna
yeah it didn't interest me I on my list
I will get to it I've heard a lot about
one of the villains being like fantastic
and that's why everyone was pissed off
that I think I've got a villain like a
race got the villain of the year for
crunchyroll Awards yeah do is the only
one I know of thus that's about the only
one you know cuz in the mean with me
yeah exactly yeah that's it what about
the what about the lord of calamity from
tales of zestiria I dropped that real
quick [ __ ] you man how can I help series
made by you foldable come on but that
was I don't know I couldn't do it I
couldn't watch to look for a beautiful
but that's all it was I prefer to play
the game so uh Briggs did you want to
ask me something about while I was gone
oh yeah you just thought like since you
got back I want to ask your opinion on
the villains from the seven deadly sins
yes yes uh I mean I thought at first
that the holy Knights were just way too
over to table just bad for bad sake
right and then it kind of it was kind of
lame but then when we figure out you
know all the stuff that's going on with
the betrayals of the Headmaster's or
grandmasters and you know messing with
demon blood I thought that was stuff was
more interesting and of course in the
manga we learned more interesting stuff
and meet more interesting villains than
in the anime so far I think yeah like I
think once you get into the manga more
that's when it gets more interesting for
anything rather than the anime villains
yeah I agree that's what's the 10
commandments come in like you've got a
bunch of badass villains but like I said
like the motivation isn't amazing it's
more just like it's it's essentially a
revenge from 3,000 years ago like for
the 10 commandments and stuff like that
like it's not I think it's an amazing
series I think it has lovable characters
and a well a really cool world they
creates friction I would say I don't
know I enjoy it but it's not amazing
yeah by the way [ __ ] Lum King says
Helsing is littie so Lydia
become a thing why what Oh
England is my city and lit he has become
a thing
Thank You Jessie Paul or whatever his
name is Logan Falls brother 91 days the
anime no no no likes 91 days yeah 91
days was good but the best villain there
is a guy called fungal he is he's Opie
know but not too that he's funny he's
funny as a villain I want to say oh no
he's not no he's not Opie but he's
badass but the way he acts his
personality he's a funny villain yeah I
mean Isana mentioned fait series but I
mean for faith series really there's
only two villains I can think of in
faith series yeah I mean there's there's
like what Gilgamesh yeah and can never
say they can we we got huh yeah that guy
yeah those two the only villain
really because I mean other than that
it's a war where people just have to
fight people so you can't really call
one side the villain because no one side
is an antagonist yeah yeah here at all
for the priest guy and I don't get it
like I don't care for him or his
motivations but I think yoga missions
are very cool villain because again he
has this you know view that the world
unless you have struggle and suffering
humanity is not gonna progress right
like people gonna become weak and
they're gonna be destroyed by you know
they're gonna destroy themselves they're
not gonna be able to handle you know
disease and stuff like that because
they're gonna become so soft and weak so
again he has he's first a lot of cool
character so he has the cool factor like
Hisoka right but then he also has a
actual ideology or motivation that makes
me think he's pretty intriguing overall
I always found a really cool how he
didn't even want the Holy Grail because
I were like at least in one of the shows
he didn't want the Holy Grail because
like he's the king of kings king of
Heroes yes any everything the world can
possibly like give ya everyone else is
fighting for it he was in a fight that
may happen to like push his ideology
yeah basically extremely cool character
and like I said they don't all have
really have a huge motivation just cuz
it's a Holy Grail war they're all
fighting for it yeah um well someone
else mentioned someone something
well protector mankind
asked about fully Cooley I think I think
he spelled alike very French like City
Coulee or something but yet the villain
in fooly cooly is basically the factory
medical Mechanica and that's I think
really an interesting concept again like
Gurren Lagann and this anti spirals
because it's not a person with a face
it's medical Mechanica which is almost a
symbol for modern society and for the
adult world where their medical
Mechanica is of a big iron that goes and
irons all planets to be flat meaning it
makes you conform right so it's all
about a simple for conformism no one
knows what they're doing in their people
and there's no you know entrances or
exits it's like the adult
it's like you're stuck in this box
you're told what to do you must conform
and if you don't like you don't even
know you're in a box because you're so
kind of like involved in this world and
that's all you know so I think that's a
very interesting concept for food yeah
and a few people I see how to set it and
someone else up there Josh there Tom oh
da da da da and Isiah
I think Isaiah again very cool villain
but I don't think he's a great villain
because we don't know enough about his
motivations at least I watched the first
two full seasons of Durarara and I want
I came on it to know more about him why
does he do what he does what is you know
why does he not like humans what does
that mean that he's not human but then
they never give us enough you know meat
on the bones for me to actually
appreciate him as a great villain as
opposed to just like a cool mysterious
guy because what you see is Toro you
show to talk yeah you see it Tora yeah
yeah yeah yeah the villain Hockman
that's a good balloon you know the giant
one B yes I built for my everyone's hate
or something like that
yep yeah yeah well I'd say she it seemed
female is it a surety I forgot I think
she seems FEMA will do body
manifestations it uses always female so
I figure they must
tenzen from basilisk he was a good
villain I don't know if you guys seen
that ye basically there's two ninja
clans and they've always been worn for
like ages in it but recently they
they've made a peace agreement the Koger
and the eager and basically the the
Shogun of that time has his two sons and
he can't make up his mind which one he
wants to become like the next in line so
basically he assigns a clan to each son
have them fight to the death
and obviously the winning one then that
means that sound assigned to it is the
next in line and basically Tenzin
he's with the Iger clan
and the whole time like throughout the
years cuz he's like kind of more like he
won't he won't dice long he can like
repair himself he won't die so he's
lived a very long time and the whole
time he's been manipulate in the war
between the clans
because his mother was an Eagle woman
who got pregnant to a coger guy yeah and
he betrayed her and he killed her yeah
but because he's got this ability as a
baby he survived and he climbed out of
his mother in it and so since then he's
been brewing his hatred for the the
Koger clan
so he's kept the war constant until
eventually you know they they wipe out
the kaga clan because that's his goal
but yeah he was a user good for them um
people are talking more eyes and I can't
believe a fraud about eyes and I think
he is a fantastic antagonist especially
like I don't like to consider anything
past the first two arcs Canon guys reach
that from my memory but his first
introduction go badass and so forth yeah
yeah I think the problem with those kind
of villains is they they all only end up
defeating themselves like yeah I mean
like oh yeah I've done this experiment
to create you and you are the one who's
gonna defeat me yeah yeah yeah and like
500 episodes later and you're still the
same villain and like Oh apparently
masterplan i manipulated everything
everything since your birth my [ __ ]
plan oh my god
it was ridiculous I don't want to talk
about that but his current introduction
was fantastic like he starts off you
think oh he looks like the good guy like
someone who's like gonna help the mean
and like the protagonist it like be a
good guy and oh [ __ ] he died out of
nowhere and then boom he's alive
actually and [ __ ] you'd be actually
antagonist in the entire show like my
mind was blown I think he's extremely
badass extremely powerful at the
beginning and it made me look forward to
watch more and then I was like kind of
let down afterwards but his introduction
was fantastic and like even his
motivation was pretty cool but they
didn't execute it that great yes
sounds like your brain trembles Briggs
yeah happy talking about it but so at
the same time I had a few people talk
about stuff so I want to bring that up
you already did talk about the anti
spiral so the guy that asked about of
your late man you said you were late so
that's why I didn't hear that part also
um a lot of people bringing up like
Marvel villains and other than the fact
they're not from anime I also think that
the problem is with comic book villains
is like they've switched the comic book
storylines and backgrounds around so
much that it's like you don't know who
the villain is anymore so it's like if
we're talking about you know the films
like The Avengers films or something
that's fine but then there's so many
different arcs in the comic books and
the different generations where it's
like you don't even know they take the
same character they recycle him and
change his background change everything
about him so that's my one problem with
long-running comics is that they do that
and then it's hard to you know which
which one are we looking at like that
the new one though you know the retro
one you the different universe is the
different arcs it's a little confusing
and yeah a few people mentioned
assassination classroom and I yeah I'm
watching that show right now I'm really
enjoying it like as a fun show to watch
not like a masterpiece but it's really
fun and funny and yeah I think
korosensei is such an interesting
villain because by definition he's a
villain because of you know what we
learned in the beginning and what his
motivations are allegedly but he's so
not a villain it's not even funny so
it's that's a really interesting example
I was thinking about that when I was
thinking about the theme for today it's
like he is such an interesting
anti-villain I guess I haven't seen
season two I really need to watch it I
want to find out like how the alley how
it ended yeah I'm just I'm just I'm just
I'm like the second half of season 2
right now what about hero killer stain
from Okinawa hero I think it's a good
villain
oh yeah this his motivation is about
like society being like like the hero
they're all about like Fame and money
now and like it's not for like the real
reason like hero should be created like
saving people so yeah I think you the
fantastic feeling in my opinion some
people don't like him one but I don't
know why he really
as well facepalm guy from Canada seems
utterly remembered mechanically the cool
build everyone the guy the villain with
the hand on it I got a key yeah yeah no
no I just yeah I don't aren't doing
doing really anything I've got from the
guy yet I mean other than him yeah okay
I want to destroy the symbol of hope I
want to destroy all my that's it but I'm
still not seeing why don't ya I mean I'm
still not really feeling his wife yeah
like as well because like a latent stain
more and like he again he's like he has
a goal that is not necessarily bad
because he wants to weed out all the
corrupt people who are not true heroes
by using the concept of heroism to
profit off of it and making society
worse off but the in terms of the league
of villains and their whole goal that
the point is that they believe that all
might is the symbol of modern society
and the values of modern society so
that's what he's based on your Western
heroes like your Americanized you know
like commercialized idea of a hero and
they believe that if they kill him they
will kill the values of society along
with him and be able to change society
and mold it to the way they want it to
be so that's their kind of motivation
their mama is still white this I mean
it's still not like there's no
background validation to why they want
to do this I don't get yeah I mean
there's no justification for it
justified like it sounds like a good
goal or whatever if you're gonna be a
villain but there's no justification for
it yeah I mean like I mean if the guy
was just oh yeah I was homeless and you
know this next guy took me in and he's
taught me and corrupted my mind with
this evilness so now I'm gonna be evil
because that's all I know
then you know I mean yeah okay you can
understand okay he's been manipulated
his whole life yeah I mean well you know
I don't know it's just
it feels weak to me really yeah like as
opposed to stay no as a clear like
ideology and goal these guys just like
yeah we want to change the world to suit
our needs but it's done that it's not as
strong I know what you mean
um a few people mentioned Adagio from
kill a kill and yeah she's an
interesting villain to it because if she
starts off as a normal person but then
because she becomes drunk on power and
fame she decides to basically become
corrupt and her mind is taken over by
the life fibers which we know is an
extraterrestrial life-form right so then
she is when she's a villain she's no
longer who she used to be she's changed
on uh probably even on a molecular level
because of the fibers but it's
definitely true that she kind of gave up
her humanity for power yeah definitely
I liked as that I like to character yeah
she's a strong coat you know I had
strong sense of values in it of strength
being like the wool in fact that I say
yeah if you can't survive not strong
enough to survive then you don't deserve
to live basically yeah I mean and yeah
it seems finis counter Deranian ism and
that would be Gilgamesh's view as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah what about you know
Gaza yeah yeah yeah yesterday doesn't
necessarily make villain per se though
that's kind of the weird thing about it
yeah yeah yeah I mean she's an extreme
young do it but you know it I wouldn't
say she's a villain cuz the whole the
whole way foo she's assisting Yuki and
Yuki's our protagonists right so she's
helping him all the way through and then
basically I don't know at one point she
then does turn on him because she wanted
him to kill her but he refused to so
then she's gonna kill him which anyway
has to happen
because there can only be one winner
otherwise all the worlds are gonna be
devoured so that doesn't make her a bad
guy yeah I mean because it has to happen
now if you don't accept that you have to
kill me then I'm gonna have to kill you
otherwise everything we've done has been
pointless because old worlds are gonna
get devoured anyway yeah I thought um
she thought she was a cool character
like shipwreck is like what about your
name who's the villain in your name yeah
the comet debater coming to broke off
that was I could relate to that for a
tool no how can you just break off like
that I mean come on the mangos better
watch it you have to read the manga the
manga as well it was very different when
you read the manga there's there's a lot
more going on but there's more like
subplots and then there's a lot more
like past where it actually ends in the
movie yeah I mean it goes on forever
past that is also yeah I recently
watched an old film called anime film
called Galaxy Express
3:9 it's from the 70s and I thought they
had a cool villain as well it was again
one of those like villains having
motivations and who is the real villain
and a lot of social commentary and it
like I watched and I realize it's it
inspired so much today like so much
stuff that I know was inspired by that
film because I watched it as I kid when
I was like 10 before him anyone anime
was and I thought it was crazy I
couldn't understand it all but I was
like man this is crazy was just on TV
randomly and then after re-watching him
knowing as much of what animes I do not
I realized how inspired how inspiring it
was and it has great music and stuff
it's really cool and yeah as some anime
film starred with the great villains
like castle in the sky I think has a
really interesting real invisible as
well and an interesting backstory
surrounding the
the whole concept of humanity and what
humanity does if it has too much power
and all that stuff right what about
karma Tschida
from from what I don't know I never gone
to persona to be honest I mean that's
what that dengan whopper whatever things
look like because they look like you
know that little teddy this with them
like you look like like the same thing
but then like by 9 what is what are some
of your favorite villains or perhaps
your favorite one if you know Oh a lot
of that's already been covered here for
characters that I really enjoy seeing I
don't necessarily have a favorite one
I've always been partial to anti-heroes
though but I yeah for a good villain a
lot of it dictates and we talk about and
that's what we've mentioned which is the
the duality these shades of grey you
know it's sometimes black and white can
be enjoyable for a story but it's it's
when you start to blur the lines between
good and evil I think that's truly what
can make a very compelling villain a
character that you can not only relate
to but can understand even more so in
some cases sympathize with that's me
that that's a character I really get
behind and enjoy yeah
a colored squid brought up ghost in the
shell and I know in the second movie I
believe it is of ghost in the shell'
when that hacker is the villain I said I
think that I was a really cool I
remembered and then having got
philosophical discussion and then you
realize first one in the first one that
the the hacker those fingers or okay I
think in second one was when the hacker
turned out to be an AI or something
right I think that was the second film
mmm
no I think the second one is the one
they tried to put in the movie you know
in a recent like Hollywood movie yeah
but like the second one I feel like is
weird
was where he has a conversation with
multiple like he's inhabiting like an
Android body and stuff and like it's
like a deep philosophical conversation
that I thought was really interesting of
like what it means to be human what it
means to come into existence all that
stuff yeah okay I thought was the first
one i was the first one cuz and that's
when they then talk about we're gonna
merge and like create an offspring and
then he was like ya know was it you'll
be you and I'll be me but we'll be
different or something you know Mason
yeah maybe so maybe I'm confusing him
but like I for some reason I thought
that that hacker was in the second film
but yeah either way it goes to the shell
is again very interesting not a black
and white situation at all it's all
about the nuances and there's a lot of
social commentary about a modern society
and where society is heading and that
always is the most interesting to me as
someone who studies philosophy and
politics and you know how society works
I think that's always really interesting
and Cory who Cory all right how about
Johan oh yeah y'all unlevered from
monster like he's I know a lot of
people's favorite villain like a roll
time so fantastic yeah he was yeah used
twisted but because every point doc
bring in and like neo-nazi group does
all doing them experiments on him and
stuff like who he eventually turned on
and killed most of them and stuff and
then they created a monster
yeah literally yes yes they did yeah but
yeah he was interesting villain he was
good but it was like you learn like the
whole story basically was him yeah cuz
like he comes in as a child
people die he disappears then it's
tracking him down and is you tracking
him down you have to then trace the
steps of his life basically so you the
whole like plot is finding out about
your heart and finding where he is which
was yeah it was interesting it was a
different way of doing it of dealing
with a villain yeah I mean
yes differently yeah yeah absolutely and
someone mentioned nights of [ __ ] on the
hour Cydonia Antonius yeah and well they
say she dona my friend you say they need
a saw so you know picasa
that's another situation like at our
contain right where it's like you're not
necessarily fighting bad guys you're
fighting a different species that
doesn't you know it doesn't think the
way you do so it's not necessarily that
it they're evil it's that there and
exist existential threat to you but that
doesn't mean that they're specifically
evil it's just like it has to happen
because the two can't coexist or can
they well no no wait no attack on titans
like that cuz i mean they can't coexist
because i mean we saw them like you know
that's the fine you know unless they get
injected you know then you know they'll
turn but if that happened then they will
remain looking human and staying human
for like the duration in their life
unless powers pass on to certain nine
people every so often and i said yeah
well they have to pass on because yeah
we're all getting into too many attack
natal spoilers i mean like the in terms
of being mindless titans and being like
a different species that doesn't think
the way you do you know the microscope
i'm our leader holly create them no I
know but I'm saying like with that
without going into that like thinking of
the just the world within the walls it's
like you're finding the Titans like air
and he hates the Titans cuz he wants a
wrench but it's almost like Moby Dick
right it's like how do you get revenge
on an animal that doesn't think like you
do that's just mindless like can you
really get revenge like you can't so I'm
thinking from in that perspective but I
think we had a great conversation guys I
think we got to wrap it up slowly
because like we got a me and goes and
gotta finish up work on a big video that
we're hoping to drop tomorrow we're
hoping so we'll see before we go I just
want to go to thank everyone in the chat
obviously for being here and chill with
us
and go through everyone here and tell
them who you are and what you do and
we'll start with cyanide
my name is soul maka I was formerly a
Viceroy on Mao Flores discs or chat
sadly I had to step down because I'm
just too busy I am currently working on
a very top-secret project right now
can't wait to unveil it someday but it's
gonna be big Thanks so maka and other
guy and by the way our discord is an act
of this court so you can come and chat
with us on a daily basis link in the
description I think odd boo good job Bob
always been like giving a link to people
who were asking for it in the chat as
well ANBU is always on top of things
let's go to briggs if he's still here I
see some guy with a tongue sticking out
instead of I am still here and Zuma
great villain not really a villain he'll
even know what he is an alien basically
I am Briggs from the YouTube channel all
day anime I turned my camera off I'm
dying of heat here guys I just didn't
want too much effort he doesn't want to
see us to see him sweating like a pig
yeah my shirt off guys can't handle us
it had all the fan chat fanservice you
know please it's not sausage fest over
here without you taking off your shirt
yeah I make facts videos and like
explained videos it's like interesting
things you wouldn't already know about
series or like explaining cool concepts
and topics in anime that's it I guess
I'm gonna be dropping by a discord I'm
gonna grab some meat quick and I'm gonna
go into general chat so download discord
and come say hi oh yeah Oh Briggs the
discord shout out the girl bro - I see
her and shout doses in the child who he
just came for the end I guess you headed
for the right cafe to start rapping I
was like hey I'm here guys what's new
enemy recon yeah
okay well sup guys ma recon here I guess
aka recon no pico aka havoc no pico you
know what I'm talking about
so I make live reactions on seasonal
anime daily and I also provide a top ten
by recommending you guys what to watch
if you guys are looking for new anime
then yeah
that's where you can find them on the
channel and of course everyone knows I
love you all and I love especially
cyanide my boy yeah are online more than
anyone else yeah thanks thanks for you
guys
Rika makes quality top 10 list but he
doesn't just talk over them you actually
make some a MV out of them and they're
really really cool so check him out link
in the description and since soul maka
didn't say anything about himself he is
a aerobic artist that hangs out on our
discord a lot so you if you want to talk
to him about a rogue a as long as you
are of age appropriate age then you can
join the discord and talk to him about
it but in private I don't want to hear
about it I don't want to hear about it I
don't wanna I want plausible deniability
yeah yeah yeah just PM me your I don't
know you'll provide it once and needs
yeah there you have it guys so yeah
leave a like if you like these streams
will be back next week at 5:00 Eastern
Standard Time doing these different
topics if you want to suggest a topic
you can leave it in the comments once
this video is loaded if you leave it in
the chat it's not going to show up but
you can leave it in the comments and
yeah thanks everyone for joining me
everyone who was here with me on the
stream everyone in the chat and until
next time see you space cowboys I love
you all jimbacca bang I almost forgot
that was horrible